did you know that there was a one piece
anime before the one piece anime and now
you can see it better than ever back in
1998 production IG produced a one piece
OVA the first the series had ever been
animated with a whole host of different
voices designs and so on and for a long
while all we've had available of that
was a 720p stream capture of the VHS
tape but that capture was riddled with a
lot of ghosting during motion but now a
group named Kino video has used some
very complicated capture technology to
get us a higher quality rip with less
ghosting and clearer detail the only
downside with this version is that there
is a pretty significant amount of
haloing that's that kind of doubling of
the image you can kind of see here but
hey if we have groups creating rips like
this now I can only imagine what may be
in store for us in the future and that
OVA is just a neat part of history that
I can't wait to see what comes for it